from my daughter days
one what causes white's tree frogs
latoria cerullia
to change color she's watched hers do so
for years too the wood frog
lithobates what causes their heart to
restart after cryopreservation
yeah heather um
let me go with the wood frog first uh
that's a new genus you're giving it
um i assume that this is um this is it's
just had a name change since i last
checked in with this frog
um if it is the frog i'm thinking of it
is in
um is present in sort of the middle uh
mid-continental north america u.s
up into southern canada and
these frogs actually get frozen solid
frozen solid not just their hearts but
during hard winters
they estimate they bare they bury under
and then
they don't even keep anything going they
just become ice cubes like if you dig
them up
and uh you drop them they shatter
and then we are not advising that you do
that they don't restart after they
shatter
frogs you heard it here first frogs do
not restart after they shatter
um unlike starfish
you could shatter a starfish uh you can
prune the legs off
yeah it's a little different from
shattering it's less dramatic
yeah yeah okay well these are the tools
we have as biologists
yeah uh so what is the actual mechanism
of restarting uh i i don't know at like
the cellular level
um but there is a kind of anti-freeze
i think in these guys um that basically
begins to circulate
as the frog begins to thaw and they can
only deal with so many
well so so slow a freeze thaw cycle and
so many of them within
x number of weeks and so you know
particularly
chaotic springs for instance can leave a
you know an iowa landscaper after these
frogs because they just they
they don't come out of it successfully
but if they thaw slowly and better off
if it's just once
um they uh they restart but i don't i
don't have there's a big black box there
in the explanation that i don't know
more about
i'm gonna take a crack at it okay i'm
gonna predict that um
predict is one of these things where
it's a prediction because i don't know
it doesn't mean nobody knows
um but i'm gonna predict that there is
a battery like
set of cells that
is positioned in the tissue
such that it does not take what little
energy it has accumulated
and fire it off too early that is to say
while the heart is still partly frozen
and therefore would damage itself or be
unable to start there is some
battery that on that thaws at the right
moment that the heart is capable of
restarting it's not too early it's not
too late
and that it sends a signal to the
pacemaker which basically
functions as a defibrillator um oh i
like that
yeah yeah i don't know if that's true
nope neither do i
yeah it's a prediction uh with regard to
the white's tree frogs
uh what causes them to change color i do
not
remember what the mechanism is on those
guys there are a number of mechanisms of
color change in
mostly reptiles but also a few frogs um
that involve basically chromatophores
these you know just
the things in the skin that can that can
flip that are often
usually uh effectively a toggle and
they're binary and they can go from one
to the other but obviously there are
some
um over in reptile space not just
chameleons that have a
of a continuum and that's a different
mechanism and i don't know what
i do cephalopod mollusks have i think a
wide range
yeah and i think they i think that
that's a different evolution entirely
whereas i think what's going on in
a few frogs and many more squamates um
is a shared i think a shared evolution
whereas the cephalopods is going to be
you know a different different evolution
of color change i'm going to say
and then some fish too and so i don't
know if the fish like the actinops like
rayfin fish that do this
um is a separate evolution from the
other vertebrates
don't know yeah and even if they are
separate evolutions probably there's
some precursor that they
share yes this is the way it is with the
vision pigments and stuff
but i think it's melancholy that causes
these frogs to
change color melancholy yeah i think
that's probably right
frogs are a sad lot oh sometimes
um i did see probably on reddit recently
somebody
posted in maybe it's the
nature is [ __ ] lit subreddit um
a video of a cephalopod i think an
octopus
um it's a child's question man oh sorry
well it's just it's a subreddit i'm just
quoting
i didn't name it um in any case they
posted a video of a and i'm sure it was
an octopus
um changing color in its
dream state which raises all kinds of
dream state did you say
how do we how do we know well because it
appears to be an adornment
also cephalopod's dream that's the thing
is it's like how many different
convergences
are because this so how is it that we
uh can so quickly say oh well color
change and cephalopods is going to be a
different evolution from color change
in vertebrates and even more easily
immediately conclude well if
cephalopods if octopi and squid or some
of them dream
that it's got to be a separate evolution
of dreaming than what we have
because we see evidence of dreams in
many mammals
i don't know if there's any evidence in
birds
but i don't think that i've seen anyone
discuss the possibility of dream state
in any of the other non-mammalian
vertebrates
which means the most recent common
ancestor of humans
mammals and cephalopods is how many
hundreds of millions of years ago
like six seven i i don't know i'm making
that number up but
more than it's early i don't know yeah i
don't know
and those organisms weren't dreaming
because we have
no evidence of dreaming in almost any
organisms that we've looked
at so these guys are dreaming says who
looks like how do we know
well you know i guess you would say uh
you would have
brain activity uh incidentally
different evolution of brains yep never
an evolution of brains but you would be
able to detect the electrical
impulses associated with processing that
is taking place while the animal's not
taking in new
data yeah and i would say you know
painting with a broad brush
that's dreams okay um it's at least
processing
whether or not there's i guess
dreams for us is always tied into visual
cortex stuff right
yep there's there's at least memory of
visual
stuff uh even i believe for blind people
right uh so uh we obviously can't
interview the occupy yet but we can't
they just don't cooperate yeah they
really they're not interested
no no uh so uh we can see that there's
processing going on but we don't know
what the subjective experience is like
for them can we
you